When you're smiling,
when you're smiling,
no.
Why did I do that?
When people evaluate great actors,
what often gets mentioned most is range,
how many different characters they can
play,
how many different emotions they can
realistically movingly show,
but I think a criteria and that's just
as telling as range is depth.
How many different ways and actor can
portray the same emotion.
I spent the last few weeks watching
pretty much every film Jack Nicholson
ever made and it's clear that the man
can do it all,
but it's also no mistake.
That intensity is calling card today.
I'd like to explore the ways that Jack
Nicholson conveys and uses anger in his
work.
The angles he approaches it from the
spins and emphases he puts on it in
order to see what makes Jack Nicholson
so great.
Anger is an emotional response or
reaction to something that reaction
manifests psychologically,
but also physically and everyone's had
that sensation of being convulsed with
anger.
What Nicholson shows again and again in
his roles is how anger can literally
possess the body like a spirit,
because I really want to know because it
was a mistake,
maybe we could do something about it.
This is the moment when anger becomes
aggression.
Half the time that aggression in
Nicholson's work is realized as actual
violence against someone else,
whether it's psychotic violence or in
some way justify the other.
Half of the time this theatrical anger
takes place in Nicholson's own personal
space.
He flails around sometimes as a threat
or a suggestion of violence to come.
A lot of the time it's just a release,
a discharge of pent up energy.
To me,
these moments,
the weird contortions and spasms that
Nicholson makes are more poignant than
actual attacks on people.
There are kind of exploration of the
relationship between body and mind and
it never feels like overacting.
I think that's because these
gesticulation are all unique to the
particular anger that they spring from.
Whether it's focused,
pointed,
anger,
or generally frustrated anger or
petulant child.
We'll have to leave.
I'm not taking any more of your time,
Nicholson,
and everybody else for that matter.
Anger can be a form of desperation,
annoys so loud that you don't have to
hear your own insecurities and Mike
Nichols,
carnal knowledge.
For example,
Nichols plays a playboy who objectifies
women and refuses to commit.
One of his lovers asks him to get
married and he explodes.
Fuck is my shoe,
or this place is a mess out half the
time you looked like it fell out of bed.
Nicholson acts a kind of anger here that
it's easy to see right through the
larger and louder it is.
The closer he is to recognizing a
vulnerability in himself.
Do you want an extra $50 a week?
Try back.
You mean you want an extra hundred
dollars?
Make this Goddamn goddamn window.
That's why he can stand up in here,
the God damn place.
That's the challenge for an actor
playing this emotion.
You're not just playing anger,
you're playing what's under it.
Most anger isn't psychotic.
It's only a thin veneer for what's
brewing below and you have to be able to
turn up the volume while preserving
traces.
Of this deeper motivation,
that's what Nicholson excels at in the
border.
For example,
Nicholson plays a border agent who gets
caught up with his partner is human
smuggling operation.
When the partner starts killing his
competition,
Nicholson realizes that he's gotten into
far the key emotion in this exchange is
an anger,
but fear,
fear of what he's gotten himself into,
fear that he won't be able to get
himself out on Nicholson bursts with
anger here,
but it's in the silent moments where the
actual feelings
like,
I don't care about your fucking money.
Fucking life is going to be fine before
I ever get involved murder.
You understand what I'm saying to you?
This is why you Nicholson's characters
seem real in their anger.
Even with great writing and great
direction.
It's only the actor who can make a
character polyphonic like more than one
thing is happening at the same time,
and even when you do that,
that particular expression of anger has
to rise out of the particular
character's personality.
For example,
take these two examples of anger which
are both underlaid with a strong sense
of superiority.
Can't handle the truth.
Son,
we live in a world that has walls and
those walls have to be guarded by men
with guns.
Who's gonna do it you,
you,
Lieutenant Weinberg,
never,
never interrupt me.
Okay?
Not if there's a fire.
Not even if you hear the sound of a thud
from my home in one week later,
there's a smell coming from there.
There can only be a decaying human body
and you have to hold Hanky to your face
because the stench is so thick that you
think you're going to faint.
Both of these men feel smarter and more
important than the person they're
lecturing too,
but the first is a lifelong military
man.
In a court of law,
Nicholson barely moves his body or head.
Every swivel of the neck is measured and
exact.
You so restrained that a simple lean
forward feels like he's lost it.
I did the job,
God damn right,
I did.
The second man is smug and in his own
space,
his movements are freer,
looser,
and they even seemed to mock great
kinnear's,
homosexuality.
Don't know not on this,
not for any reason you get me,
sweetheart.
No two expressions of anger are the
same,
not in real life and not in Nicholson's
work.
Sometimes his anger,
his comedic,
sometimes cartoonish.
Sometimes it's quiet,
sometimes it's misplaced and sometimes
it's deeply,
deeply wounded.
Whatever you're doing stuff,
whatever you're doing,
stop it.
I hope you die.
I hope you fucking die.
Watching so much of Nicholson's acting,
you start to get a sense of the larger
shape of anger as a human phenomenon.
It's extremes,
its physicality and it's dangerous,
but also its necessity in the course of
a life.
None of us can avoid anger.
You can't remove it from the
constellation of feelings,
but you can't understand it.
Jack Nicholson has a wide range of
talents as wider range as an actor,
as anybody else,
and yet if all he ever did was give us
these 60 years of insights into anger,
it would still be a career well spent.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
That was a lot of Jack Nicholson movies
to see,
but it was totally worth it.
You learn a lot by watching a master at.
Thanks for watching that and thank you
to the great courses plus for sponsoring
this video.
If you don't know what it is,
the great courses plus is an on demand
video.
Learning service basically means it's
got over 70,000
online video lecture series from some
Great Ivy League professors and other
professors about all kinds of subjects,
math and history and archeology,
but one that I think meshes with what we
were just talking about with acting is
this course by Daniel Robinson called
the great ideas in psychology,
sort of which go all along the history
of psychology to,
to overview what's been talked about and
discover it.
And,
and that's sort of my wheelhouse.
So I love to learn that kind of stuff.
Check that out.
If you go to the great courses
plus.com/nerd
writer,
you can get a 30 day free trial.
You can find that as the first link in
the description down there.
Um,
after that it's 1490 $9 a month.
I think it's really cool.
If you like learning,
I think you'd really love it.
Thanks guys for watching.
I will see the rest of you next
Wednesday.